the Prime Minister beginning of this
morning a tude of the country her
attempt to sell the plan for brexit to
the public at large the trouble does lie
ahead with nearly a hundred Conservative
MPs set to vote against it well let's
speak now to the Cabinet Office minister
David Livingstone joining us from
Westminster this morning mr. Ludington
very good morning all of you every day
that passes more and more names add
themselves to the list saying that they
will not vote with the party leader not
vote with the Prime Minister will not
support to deal how confident are you
that you will get the yes won't you need
oh I think it's clearly devoted a it
would be a difficult one to win but I
think that we have time between now and
the 11th to make the case that even more
importantly for MPs in Parliament to
listen to the message coming up from
British business in all parts of the
country that they want this deal done
the last thing that is needed for
investment and job creation in this
country is yet more uncertainty and
businesses saying this very very
strongly indeed to get this done and I'm
finding you know talking not just to my
own constituents but visiting other
parts of the country as well the message
coming up from older people is very much
now however we voted leave or remain we
want this sorted they rather admire the
resilience and determination of the
Prime Minister to go out and fight for a
decent compromise I think most people
accept it's a compromise
but it's one that actually does deliver
a close economic partnership with the EU
for the future that's good for jobs and
living standards in Britain but at the
same time delivers on the result of the
referendum actually leaving the EU with
with all that entails but Minister just
in terms of that close economic
partnership that we have with the
European Union I mean Donald Trump does
have a point doesn't it that when you
are unable to diverge as indeed it
appears to the extent that you might
want to which it appears from the
political declaration we will not be
able to it's impossible to sign
free-trade agreements the likes of which
at
brexit ears have been telling us would
be the easiest thing possible I mean the
United States if we want to sign an FTA
with them where's our competitive
advantage if we still continue to align
ourselves with the European Union well I
actually contest what you just said the
text of the agreement says in terms that
the United Kingdom's gonna have an
independent trade policy now what is
true is that during the temporary
transitional arrangements while we can
negotiate free trade agreement to other
countries there will be some constraints
on how they can be implemented while
those transitional arrangements are in
place those drop away we have a fully
independent trade policy but but I don't
I've never thought that negotiating a
trade deal with the United States or
anybody else was going to be easy
President Trump has always said he puts
America first he'll fight hard for
American interests any trade talks we
need to fight equally hard for British
interests whether we're talking to
United States or to Japan or China or
any other country to everything but
surely it's always been an either/or if
we want to continue to have as close to
frictionless trade with the European
Union as possible then we need according
to the European Union to maintain at
least the facade of regulatory alignment
if we want to sign free-trade agreements
with the rest of the world and benefit
from them we need to be able to diverge
from a relationship with the European
Union can't have both it's the the
common external tariff of the common
commercial policy the two elements of EU
practice that involve the EU acting
collectively for free-trade agreements
but the the future partnership document
that was agreed on Sunday by us and the
eu-27 says in terms that the UK is going
to have an independent trade policy
there's a transitional period to be
worked through first just as there was a
transitional period when we join the EU
you can call it whatever you like you
can call it whatever you like but if the
future trading relationship between US
and the United Kingdom is based on this
single market the customs union I mean
it doesn't matter what you call it but
we won't be able to diverge in the way
in which Boris Johnson perhaps even Liam
Fox have suggested that they would
prefer but we made it clear that we're
not staying in the customs union and the
the single market
where we're aiming for yes a close
free-trade agreement with the European
Union just as we want to have good
free-trade agreements with other
countries around the world and I don't
see an incompatibility about those two
things what happens and they you you
spoke earlier on about business the
business community wanting us to get on
with this that they want it concluded
one way or t'other I mean what do you
say to the business community you are
asking an entirely legitimate like what
happens what happens if you can't
convince enough of your party colleagues
to vote for the dealer's proposed by
Tereza me
I think the --use made it very clear
that they're not prepared to reopen the
package that was agreed in on Sunday
last weekend for the 27 EU countries
this has been a very difficult process
they've had to make some compromises and
concessions that move from their
previous positions and you can tell from
the flack Michel Barnier has had from a
number of European governments in the
last few days that they they think that
this is has been a really difficult to
agree which they will invade recognises
that so what happens though if your
colleagues within the Conservative Party
ignore that vote no I mean what happens
next if the the one certainty is that
there would be much increased
uncertainty because I think you would
have some people some people does that
mean what it means is that there would
be in those circumstances there will be
some people in Parliament who would be
pushing very hard for a No Deal exit
from the EU and there'll be other people
in Parliament would be pushing very hard
to drop brexit altogether to find a way
of defeating the reversing the outcome
of the referendum but what what I think
MPs have to focus on in the next 10 days
is the reality that there is not some
sort of perfect alternative that meets
all their wishes and first preferences
that is there if only they put aside the
actual compromise deal that has been
negotiated and which is on the table I
think if they look at the compromise
deal that is on offer
they will see that this works well for
the interests of people in the UK a
close trading partnership better than
that that Canada has a close security
partnerships are police and justice
systems could continue to work together
against terrorism and against serious
and organised crime from people
smuggling to drug trafficking those are
things that are very much in the
interests of people from all political
opinions in the UK and all parts of the
UK so we are clear that in the event of
Parliament saying no things will be
unclear but in terms of your own party I
mean is this a point at which we all
have to say you know Teresa may has be
held on longer than many people expected
she has brought a deal back from the
European Union that the 27 have agreed
to if she doesn't get the vote if she
doesn't get the support surely at that
point the question has to be why are you
still Prime Minister no not at all I do
I don't see that the fundamentals can be
wished away by gossip about changing a
party leader the the truths about the
position of the 27 other countries in
this negotiation will remain true the
very difficult fine balance of
parliamentary arithmetic between the
different parties will remain the case
the day after as well as the day before
so those basic facts are not going to go
away and I think that the very last
thing the Conservative Party needs is
all the upheaval and the division that
would be created by a leadership contest
the one thing that people out there
notice about political parties is when
they are divided and they are squabbling
amongst themselves because voters quite
recently turn around and say well if you
really can't stand one another why
should we trust you with the future of
the country that's the lesson we learned
as a Tory party the hard way in the
years running up to a landslide defeat
in 1997